but this is an annual event so as she
was saying that somebody hacked the TV
station or somebody who probably this
cost them their job showed what's going
on in Gaza watch
this Islam net is raising funds to
establish a Masjid and Community Center
in Norway and they urgently need your
support this donation will be a sar for
you because every person that comes a
step closer to Allah through your
donation you will in be reaping a reward
click the link and donate what you can
brothers and sisters and dear friends CV
news in America was either hacked or
somebody who has a heart be they a
Muslim or non-muslim for that matter cuz
there have been millions of non-muslims
around the world standing up and
speaking out against the atrocities the
genocide the Massac that's happening by
the occupiers that's what they are yes
they are thieves if any Muslim country
any Muslim was to do what they were
doing the whole entire Globe will stand
you see that they do not see Muslims as
humans that you can see that they he see
as as un they have dehumanized us to a
level where they can openly openly talk
about the masculine of children and
babies openly let's see what happened
for oursel in here is what happened as
they were broadcasting uh the news an
event a signature event is happening
here in Toronto later this evening our
Allison Hurst joins us now with more on
what is planned in Allison it's
typically a celebration but of course
this year is very different yes there's
a lot going on right now and but this is
a time where they're hoping that they
will all be able to come together there
have been Crews coming by bringing the
pieces to begin the setup ahead of
tonight's event it will be a seven or
8ot manora that is set up here on the
stage you might be able to see behind me
some of the multicolored pieces uh that
will make up that manora and cruise we
expect will be back sometime within the
hour to continue setting up ahead of
tonight's event but this is an annual
event so as she was saying that somebody
in the back back CTV News either hacked
somebody hacked the TV station or
somebody who probably this cost them
their job showed what's going on in Gaza
watch
this Bora will go up this afternoon and
be lit tonight there will be dignitaries
and members of government will be in
attendance along with the community
there will also be music and typical
Hanukkah foods
for
anti-Semitism is
being give your mic I mean that's really
what Kaneka is about it's about lighting
a candle and darkness goes away and so
our view our approach our belief is come
with a positive message come with a a
message of light and and goodness and
darkness will eventually
disappear we're having some technical
difficulties there with Allison's mic uh
we'll certainly have more tonight and CV
news and of course you guys had some
technical difficulties there because
that's the last thing you would ever
want to show anybody for that matter
would you just act like nothing is
happening and like I said before
brothers and sisters that Subhan Allah
as Muslims we are supposed to be these
barbarians apparently in our religion it
tell us tells us to go and attack and
kill innocent men women and children
ironically except Islam anyone and
everyone has been doing that to the
Muslims for the past the last century
rather than Muslims isn't that ironic
that you are accusing us that our book
teaches us which it never does in a
single place where I've confronted the
far right on multiple occasions ever
seen not only that you never ever see
Muslims outright condoning that if Isis
or anyone for that matter was doing
atrocities which they we were condemning
them but you do not see that with the
Zionist you do not see that with the
Layman of a Zionist your day-to-day Joe
Zionist who's going to job he is
outright promoting genocide and Massacre
you've never seen that from Muslims we
have outright and vocally spoke about
even the imams speak against those
individuals and group terrorist
organizations who have gone and
committed atrocities in the name of
Islam and we have condemned it but you
see them from all Zionist I'm talking
about by the way from your lay man to
the IDF soldiers to the newscast to the
PMs to the MPS from all backgrounds yes
those who are business all of them are
saying what outright calling for a
genocide you cannot make this up and
then you've got crackhead clown
individuals who are supporting them and
why are they supporting them why is the
Christian Lobby the Israeli the Zionist
Lobby in America which is majority
Christians by the way you know why they
just want the coming of Jesus so they
can end up massacring the the Jews
that's what they want to do that's what
they want about they're just like listen
we don't get how it's done as long as
it's done when Jesus comes and we're
going to rule the world Etc that is the
reality that's happened and I want to
salute the person who hacked or even
works for CTV News went ahead and did
this salute to you my friend because
this is what we need from every single
one of you guys do not quit now and do
not Stow down now carry on sharing those
posts carry on boycotting carry on
giving donations toaza and carry on in
getting close to Allah subh making Dua
for the 20 plus thousand people who have
been massacred an absolute genocide
brothers and sisters carry on and keep
an eye on this channel where I will be
talking more about products you can
boycott inshallah till next time
Al the prophet sallallahu alhi wasallam
said whoever builds a Masid for the sake
of Allah subhana tala Allah will build
for him a similar house in jenah on that
day where Allah subhana tal tells us
that our books will be given and every
little atom weight of Good Deed you've
done will be there and imagine you see a
mountain and you're like what a lucky
person which righteous person and Allah
says this is for you for me yes what did
I do you allowed people to pray you
built a Masjid I never had the money to
build a Masjid oh Allah you helped you
gave towards it and Allah gives you the
reward of as if youve built it donate
now guys and do not delay and share the
video for extra
[Music]
Rewards